here we go and here are flow I'm
thinking stuff I can't believe ever got
me rhyming at the thinking [ __ ] I grab
the microphone lyrically our bond flows
going up in Boston freestyle to Toronto
freestyle yo it's far vital gotta say
what's up to Evan Carmichael priest out
I come off of these one verbs yes I
freestyle off the book v one word yo we
doing this in front of the camera my
name is Tony mozi you're only chrony
ain't no amateur release and stamina yo
it's like this I let it linger I got my
man heaven he's wearing the five fingers
from Vibram it doesn't matter cuz I'm
rhyming off the mind and one time unsign
him the mic is getting close to my chin
does it matter cuz I grab the mic and
flow from within yeah it's like that
check it out MCS imma breathe because
you know what I just had a sip of Green
Team my rap is on my raps are bomb can't
believe I eat emcees up like a French
macaron you see me I do it in three of
these perspectives my name is Tony
what's up it's a Scottish clan the name
is actually French way back yeah car is
from so it's from Michael so we have our
own Scottish claim we got our tartan we
got like the the kilts and all that it's
a small Scottish claim but originally
French that's awesome man so okay going
back to when you were 19 years old and
of course you know you had your business
then right how is it living with your
parents you know at that time like
trying to run this business at 19 years
old like how what was that like
experience like for you uh my parents
were super supportive I never had issues
with them you know believe came from
them they always taught me anytime I had
a problem anytime I had frustration they
would tell me I'm Evan castelia
Carmichael I could do anything that I
believe I can so they were super
supportive of my journey
that being said though I think people I
think you still get to choose your your
a lot in life so in the book and your
one word wherever it is somewhere we
profile two different NBA players and
one of them sees got MBA like top of the
line you know you made it you're in the
show one guy is like I'm here because of
my parents cuz it supported me and there
were nothing but love all the way
through and that's why I'm here and
another guy another NBA all-star they're
both all-stars the other guy says my
parents were they sucked they didn't
support me at all and that's why I'm
here
right so like one had the best friends
of all time one had the worst parents of
all time and they both end up in the NBA
so something you need to have great
parents or you need to have bad parents
it's how you react to the situation that
you decide to take control of your life
and you've been doing this YouTube thing
for a long time about at least 10 years
or a lot about 10 years almost November
Wow November 20 2008 is when I got my
channel I don't know when I started like
you know you just get the channel I get
the hit the the domain name family I
don't want to actually started making
videos I got to look at it but the
Masters yeah but it's been a while it's
been a while so so what inspired you to
make that very first video on your
YouTube channel
I think the first video my youtube
channel is a Walt Disney lessons learned
Bill Gates saved my company I'd never
met the man but by looking at his story
I sold the software I had a software
company I was struggling that felt super
worthless and
the thing that saved me was realizing I
just asked myself the question I'm not
the first kind of try to sell soft
before what am I missing
who's figured this out and I looked at
Bill Gates and how he started and I
learned from that and applied it to my
business and we started to grow so I
wanted to teach other people how to
model success and so I think the first
video is Walt Disney another one of the
people I looked up to and telling his
story and way to learn from his success
and it's worth going back and watching
because I'm super awkward and nervous
and in a suit and sitting down and like
the lowest energy of all time but I said
that's how you start you know you suck
at the start and you just keep getting
better every day that's awesome I'm
going back to the very first thing like
wedding oh I'm thinking about your book
you're one word like what inspired you
to do those that very first page what
said what like top of you that said you
know what I'm gonna get to this first
page and write it I never thought I want
to write a book my agent said you need a
book book opens doors book could be
speaking gigs but gets you brand deals
I'm like no man not anymore like my
youtube channel gets me speaking things
and my youtube channel can get me lots
of stuff I don't need a book
so I never wanted to write a book it was
it was not on my radar then as I started
going through developing the one word
methodology just for myself I thought
you know what to share this how do I
share this I felt like a book format
just fit better to get the message out
as opposed to a series of videos so
that's why I wrote the first book my
inspiration comes from my pains have
talked about that a lot that the purpose
comes from your pain and my struggle of
just suffering so much as an
entrepreneur in the early days and made
me want to make the path a little bit
easier for others but it's because I
I love entrepreneurs I struggled so much
as an entrepreneur I just I feel I feel
the mission that all these people are on
I just want them to win so badly and if
me spending an extra five minutes with
somebody makes the shift for them to go
home and start doing the thing that they
need to do I can help be an unlock I I
just I want to do it I need to do it
I'll probably go home you know later
tonight and crash hardcore but while I'm
in the zone of helping entrepreneurs it
just I just get more seeing I just pick
it up it's like I don't need to eat I
don't need to go to the bathroom I just
want to I just want to help man so this
is this is fuel man this is whew I'm
gonna feel it later in a couple hours
for sure but right now this is fuel this
is my drug helping entrepreneurs is my
drug awesome if you could think of any
book randomly off your head that like
was meaningful to you what would it be
my favorite book growing up was a book
called radicals and visionaries by
Thaddeus Juarez out of prints you can't
pick it up and it's honestly not that
good a book but I loved it because what
it did was it told the stories of you
know 40 famous entrepreneurs or so in
three to five pages in what I did was I
read i read a story every morning and it
helped make me feel like my entrepreneur
jeans were possible and it gave me some
strategies that i can use but also just
the motivation like oh this is how they
started from nothing i already have more
than what they had when they started so
i can do it too and that is a big
inspiration for what I do on my youtube
channel and what I did with my second
book right the daily injection of
learning from successful people want to
get strategies but also just to feel
like I can do it I can believe in myself
more so if you I think if you picked up
the book now if you found it out of
print
you may not be that impressed but at the
time there was that was the only one
that I knew of that did this so I read
it every day like don't don't buy it
like that don't buy it at a garage sale
it's not it's not worth right like I
think I think I think my youtube videos
are better I think my top ten rules book
is better I think you'll learn more from
it I think there's probably other books
that are better but at the time it was
the only thing so it's it has
sentimental value to me more than
anything else like you know that
whatever you have an old pair of shoes
that might have sentimental value to you
but it means nothing to anybody else but
you want to keep it so okay I did
youtube channel also you have a music
playlist that's awesome you know you
also give inspiration in that Avenue as
well what would you say is a favorite
hip-hop song rap song of yours
Eminem lose myself all-time classic I
used to listen to that a lot when I had
my early entrepreneur days and just even
the beat like the words are awesome but
just as soon as it comes on it's like
even now like if I'm ever in a hole I
think the fastest way to get out of a
dark hole is music put on any song that
that makes you want to move I think what
we end up doing was we put on songs that
we are currently feeling so if you're
feeling negative or sad you put on a
really sad sappy song it just
contributes to your feeling even more
sad where music is the fastest way I
think to change your your state your
mindset immediately and so put on the
song that you want to feel so the 8-mile
you know mm it's like unstoppable right
that's what I want to feel so I put it
on and
I'm bouncing and getting my energy back
so that's my all-time sweet and so last
question um say there's an individual
out there I mean I've met them or myself
but I like to hear your perspective they
talk about how they have an idea whether
it's an idea for a business or an idea
of some kind that they want to put out
via social media like what is this what
should they do like because they're like
always confused like well I have this
idea but I don't know about going about
it like what are your ideas to like to
nudge them to to get it out and go on
social media just force yourself to
whenever you feel worried about the
judgement of other people then you have
to go and do it why are you afraid of
putting out your idea your freedom
people aren't afraid of failing they're
afraid of failing in front of somebody
else people are people are creative of
if people are afraid of wrapping right
right they'll wrap all day in the shower
but they won't get out they won't get
out in the commons and go on rap because
they're not afraid of failing it's that
other people are watching them and so
training yourself that whenever you feel
yourself playing small in your life
because of somebody else's opinion of
you then you have to go and do that
thing and the win is not in the result
of whatever happens the win is that you
did the thing and you're releasing the
fear of the judgement so if you have an
idea and you're afraid of launching it
it doesn't matter if the idea works or
not what matters is that you conquered
the fear of launching it and that will
give you the courage to launch something
else and something else and something
else and eventually it's gonna work
thank you guys thank you very much Evan
this is Evan crying that you should
visit his channel look at the link in
the description below and please hit the
subscribe and the notification about
it's your boy Tony mosey the rhyming
book reviewer take care you know off the
throne so you can spit off some poems go
off and roam from off the dome it's the
freestyle have to spit your freestyle
raps tag a friend so you can compete all
that your cellphone's your weapon you
said that's the microphone give well
know respected I think you need to you
need to ditch the book of your thing
okay do the ditch the rhyming book
review thing yeah okay and why cuz
you're much bigger than that niche okay
cuz you've got way more to offer than
just rhyming book reviews so what would
you think what would be some areas you
think I whatever you want okay like
you've you've created this identity for
yourself which is great but then it
becomes a trap that the only thing you
do is rhyming book reviews huh you've
got way more talent than just doing book
reviews you can keep doing it well it's
fine yeah but the identity that you
build for yourself then that becomes who
you are and your your just keep a bowl
of way more I wouldn't even identify
myself as or anybody that's not yet
that's not your name should be just not
who you are
I'm 20 mosey right 20 Moe's and it but
even like behind the book review is what
is learning is right self-improvement
and build the best edutainment platform
on the word in the world I'd you to my
big my big vision great so that's what
you lead with and you start you start
shifting from well however you want to
brand yourself a neighborhood like your
so yeah like you know you came into the
into the coffee shop yeah whatever he
was called yeah just you crushed him and
it's like he's going that's great
now if you actually scripted it out and
did other stuff that could be even
better but that was solid man all the
freestyle yeah oh yeah that was good man
like you were you there oh it was good
like he was rhyming it and like if it's
just you've got so much more talent and
just being like it's a nice it's a nice
gimmicky niche thing but like right when
you gave it to me is like hey this is
solid great I'm happy to I love a lot of
people expressing themselves and sharing
but it's just you're just capable of so
much more
the only reason why is because I was
told a very valuable piece of
information
Jpop and I was like you should focus on
one thing and
Piper niche and then eventually start to
branch out which is true when you just
told me so like I wanted to start with
one little thing first and then blossom
through time but I mean yeah you're
right about that like thing is you
already have the talent to do more okay
I do interviews I do interviews and I do
but play with it who care interviews you
do - it doesn't matter what you do next
just do something next okay more
interviews or freestyle about something
you want to talk about chump or you want
to talk about like Boston Commons or
City love or entrepreneurship or your
struggles whatever but wouldn't that be
- what places for the viewer keep it all
within entertainment okay so edutainment
Amish you know IRA Tommy yeah so just
like you yells everything out right
right was like you go to the bathroom
like wake up and go to the bathroom
right like he'll motivate you go to the
bathroom yeah just that's he'll get you
motivate to do anything right yeah now
he also has a message he's not doing
stupid stuff like that but it's the
energy transfer that matters more before
they'll hear your words they have to
feel your energy and that's what Eric is
amazing at is he the greatest thought
leader of all time maybe not but he can
move people because he has more energy
than them you already have it you have
the talent you have the energy
you're not like struggling to find
yourself and like I'm super nervous
every time I'm making a book review
right right like it's it's now almost
too gimmicky and my fear is that you now
just blocked yourself in too much box
was aroused yeah about that one so start
playing with it yeah just play with it
okay I just feel you have so much more
truth to share truth every artist why do
you love them because they're singing
truth so the fun but within the finest
truth why does it matter why does
education matter so much like what's
your story where did you come from why
do you love learning so much how did it
save you why is why is the entertainment
part so important as well this guy was
saying like how much of myself do I
share everything it's the only way you
win if all you get up on stage and say
guys you need to speak you need to read
greetings great it'll save your life
go read here are five books nobody's
gonna listen to that crap right but but
like even if those five books are the
greatest books of all time you need to
transfer that energy first people should
leave every single conversation with you
feeling what you want inspire passion
feeling passion passion not because your
passion like that helps but you yeah
like you you it you you see there the
kindling and the and the newspaper and
the gas you just you like that flame
every but every conversation you have
with somebody they should leave feeling
passion right coming from my core coming
from the core and the end of the comfort
and the serving and the serving right
it's like you want to serve them
you want you want people to feel like
what and that comes back to your
painting your story-wise passion so
important right how many people don't
have passion how does that frustrate you
and make you super upset well I plan on
changing a lot about my brand including
instead of going high burnishing instead
of just thinking about one idea you know
cuz I'm thinking about rhyming book
reviews I know I'm bigger than that and
as Evan Carmichael told me he says dude
you are you are the brand
Toni mozi is the brand not the rhyming
book reviewer and it's true for me just
doing writing book reviews I'm just
pigeon holding myself alright guys I
love you guys I'm out altruistic world
domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful I
understand why I'm here I think because
I am so open I wanted to think unseen
it's a bloody brief life all of you have
the potential for enormous success if
you want to know what Gary Vee DJ Khalid
Oprah and others know about empire
building that most people miss check out
the link in the description for a free
bonus video
you